[Music]
little dear like words that come to mind
with belly dancing sensual sexy belly
dancing it's just like a sexy dance
something I want to tap into is being
able to be in charge of my body and
really feel sexy belly dancers have a
very wavy belly my body just doesn't
move like that I've got beautiful long
dancers legs but my belly I put a lot of
Chipotle into it so it just hangs out I
don't feel like I'm going to be sexy I
will try
hopefully I'm good at distracting people
with some pouty lips and some smoldering
eyes let's start off by warming up those
hips you know what we need for this
crucial piece of costuming and that is
your coin belt the coin belt was
incredible I I didn't know this was
gonna come with such elaborate costuming
it was literally like the icing on the
cake because when you're shaking you
really feel and you just come alive when
we found out that having a belly is
celebrated in belly dancing I was happy
because I got some goodies down there
Egyptian walk I don't know what that is
a lot of that practice walking around in
a circle with this I felt like a rooster
I was born to shimmy shimmy egg is just
sort of like hey look at me
look at this guy I've got fairly big
feeling my rhythm is terrible yeah
I'm going forward and then I'm sucking
in and I had like a big bowl of pasta
right before it was just like a big
belly that wouldn't move I didn't really
feel sexy I was rolling my body in the
wrong way belly dancing is hard I didn't
know it was so much like it's not often
that you get to dance with a live band I
felt like a little majestic Prince boy
the way that they played their little
drums for us it was truly one of the
great experiences of my life
and I've been to Santa's Village
bellydance is traditionally performed
celebratory events like weddings a lot
of it is really about your interaction
with the audience and being very playful
with the audience there's a lot of work
in the fates and the expressions because
when you're moving toward the audience
you're sort of like oh oh watch out here
I come
and then suddenly when they're like yes
come here oh no no no rolling back three
you can be a little bit flirty and like
smile at the audience as you're moving
back oh I'm sleepy
Oh bye see you later got to take a
little nap we all got that yeah it's a
fine line between creepy and sexy and
that line is on the veil add in the
level of mystery like capes are like a
superhero so graceful do you think you
guys can turn as you do that oh sure did
get trapped in the veil but you know
what happy to get lost in that it's my
own little world in there are you going
side to side when you go side to side
are you just moving your head I was okay
I've been those other two they enjoy the
veil I make it a part of me you're very
mysterious you see me
oh you can't touch me my eyes can get
very smoldery
I love that veil the motion is back back
back
we're very good at performing when Emma
was dancing with us and then she cut us
loose and things it was a lot a lot of
choreography that I wasn't expecting I
would be lying if I said I wasn't
overwhelmed with the three of us the
failure just compounded him because I'd
be looking at Robin he was probably
looking at me I was probably looking at
Karl and all of us had no idea what we
were doing you have time to practice
before you perform it
no wait laughs right I should have known
she wouldn't let us just do it and then
be like wow yeah that was fun All Right
see you later one little surprise that I
have up my sleeve is that I have ordered
them their own costumes oh my god I love
that costume he's tiny
silky little vests giant poofy pants
just adds to the immersion
makes me feel like the real deal when I
put on that outfit I felt a little bit
like Aladdin I like a lot and we're
gonna look incredible
we are destiny selling emma has also
told us that it is customary for
audiences to boost the morale of the
dancers with a very elegant which I hope
our audience instinctually knows to do
I was very nervous going up
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
tried to keep eye contact and just
really really seduce the crowd I
basically just follow chain and Carl and
they nailed it it was really interesting
to learn about the dance there's
something very distinctive about it you
do feel like you're embracing another
culture you don't you had a good time we
had a good laugh too she laughed a lot
man someone signed these guys get them
on tour tens across the board when's the
next one a minute I don't maybe I was
swept up in the moment but I don't
recall hearing any you forgot that's all
I was waiting for